le 25 juillet 1909 louis blériot fait
qu'ils ont fait à la fois sa conception
du monoplan et les couleurs françaises
en suivre dans la manche pour la
première fois à 60 kilomètres à l'heure
louis blériot recevra pour cet exploit
lui livre sterling offerte par le
journal britannique daily mail
1935 funérailles nationales en autriche
pour le chancelier angry birds dollfus
assassinés par les nazis à vienne le 25
juillet 1950 quand au pouvoir dès 1932 à
l'âge de 40 ans s'inspirant à la fois
des méthodes de mussolini et de hitler
dollfus n'était pas un démocrate modèle
mais il était avant tout autrichien et
il l'avait prouvé en refusant de s'unir
plus étroitement avec l'allemagne nazie
pour cela il devait disparaître